hello what's your favorite scary movie
Oh probably signs actually sides isn't a
scary movie we're talking about signs of
scary movie there aren't even any good
kills insides blood does not mean scary
rated-r does not mean scary be pg-13 and
still be scary City is scare the crap
out of me
M night Shyamalan a ding dong Luo man I
all sit here and I will defend signs all
freaking night screw forum hello Sydney
scream for reunites the original cast
from the first three films like Neve
Campbell Courteney Cox David Arquette
and a slew of newcomers with director
Wes Craven who's very famous for films
just like these he's been making scary
shocker movies for years and to be
honest he's very off and on some of his
movies are awful I mean some are really
bad and then others are actually very
good so one of his best films are course
the screen films - scream 3 which I'm
not a huge fan of but it's it's ok red
eye is actually also one of his good
films and the people under the stairs
and of course Nightmare on Elm Street
and a new nightmare he's a very good
director actually for some horror films
this film has never Campbell's character
Cindy coming back to the town of
Woodsboro to promote the new book that
she wrote meanwhile there's some new
young ones on the block hayden
Panettiere Emma Roberts Rory Culkin from
signs and that ways big it's really
weird
and of course there's a mass killer on
the loose now the thing that's great
about the screen films is that it pokes
fun at the genre now so many of horror
movies from the 80s and 90s and all the
way to today are so cliched same stuff
happens shower scenes somebody goes
outside somebody opens the door the
somebody there Oh burns but the hands on
the show
oh gosh what's going to happen and
that's where the reasons when screen
phones work so well is because it shows
all that stuff but it knows it's being
cliched there are scenes in this film
like there's a police officer in the car
and he looks at this friend he goes I'll
be right back and he goes wait I
shouldn't say that should I
there's just clever stuff like that all
throughout this film that makes it
really enjoyable to watch and honestly
in my opinion the best scream sequels so
far I really just had a lot of fun with
this movie it was just fun from
beginning to end one of the things that
I really really appreciated were the
actors they really put a lot into this
material I mean they were really
invested in it you gotta realize that
this movie is doing it's not meant to be
100% serious scary movie this film pokes
fun at everything that is so tired and
scary movies nowadays all the cliches of
the past decade that we've grown to hate
torture porn you know these disgusting
movies like saw this film this trashes
those movies the fact that like in scary
movies now everyone has to be filming it
you know it's some kind of handheld
found-footage thing trashes that it's
just it makes fun of all of it and I
love it for that at the same time I was
under stood in the story Neve Campbell
is beautiful and she is really good in
this film she just she knows this
character Courtney Cox is good as well
David Arquette is good emma roberts is
good hayden Panettiere is actually very
good in this movie she was on my
favorite characters a lot of times in
horror movies nowadays the ones that
take themselves serious so to speak the
young actors and actresses are like so
upset that they're in these four movies
because they just want to be an actor or
an actress you know what I mean they're
like oh gosh I mean saw 15 so I'm going
to be crappy the actors in this film
know that they're in a movie that is
poking fun at the stupidity of all those
horror films they're like they're
relishing it they're getting it they're
all they're doing a very nice job I was
very impressed with the actors of the
film also the film looks very nice Wes
Craven did a really nice job with a look
at this film it just reminded me so much
of the 90s I was born in 88 the my time
conception was the 90s I am a 90s guy
all the way so my complaints of the film
are West Craven uses the something
sneaks up on you scare way too much it's
not very effective anymore especially
after seeing insidious and being scared
crapless I was very much into the
character
this film Deb Campbell's awesomer
character is so cool like I just really
like her how she's so brave and
everything is a really strong woman
character this is a fun teen movie you
know it really captures the the feel of
the today's teen generation it does a
good job with that I just love the fact
that a movie like this can poke fun
stupidity and the cliches out there
today of horror movies and at the same
time being able to reinvent itself I
really don't have any problems with it
because to be honest I know what this
movie was trying to be I'm going to give
screen for three and a half out of four
stars it's actually one of my favorite
movies of the year it's a lot of fun if
you like scary movies you could like the
other screen films you'll probably like
this one too Mel Gibson was so good men
will be walking finish for goodness
sakes Rory Culkin who was later in this
movie called scream 4 that was also
really good I mean come on it's a really
good movie man just don't don't judge me
for liking science